لذلك قبل أزمة الطاقة فعل
تكلف الطاقة حوالي 20٪ من طاقتنا
التكاليف المتغيرة هنا في الموقع
صنعوا هم الآن
زاد إلى أكثر من 60 إلى 70٪
رأينا بالفعل في يونيو أن
ذهب السلامة من الغاز ونحن
قررنا في ذلك الوقت أننا
سيعيد بناء محطة الطاقة لدينا
على الجانب حتى نتمكن من التبديل إلى زيت التدفئة
مقدرة
[موسيقى]
منذ التطلع إلى الأمام وهي بالفعل في
مناقشة مع بايرنول وكذلك المدينة
Kelheim ثم جمعية الموانئ
في القاعة هنا على المدى الطويل
نحن نبني حلًا باستخدام الهيدروجين
نريد واحدة من المزارع الكبيرة الأولى في
بافاريا الذي يتحول إلى الهيدروجين
[موسيقى]
لكن كما قلت ، يجب أن تكون في هذه الأزمة
ترى المعنى على أنه فرصة
التفكير في كيفية القيام بالإنتاج
منظم في المستقبل على ما أعتقد
على المواد الخام أو الأحافير ، إذا جاز التعبير
يجب وضع المواد الخام بشكل دائم أيضًا
من إنتاج الطاقة التي تطورت
أظهرت أن هذه لا تزال طريقة محفوفة بالمخاطر
هذا يترك الشركة على الأقل
لا شيء آخر على المدى المتوسط
ثم الأمر متروك لك لإعادة توجيه نفسك
[موسيقى]